l'île de loisirs de 50 ans ieline est
devenue une terre de sport pendant 2
jours organisé en partenariat avec le
CNOSF l'événement santé vous sport
proposé de découvrir une dizaine de
disciplines dans le parc ce samedi 17 et
dimanche 18 septembre objectif viser un
large public on a des groupes de de
jeunes ou moins jeunes qui viennent en
tenus de sport qui viennent pour pour
s'initier à des activités sportives
pratiquer du sport et par contre on
touche aussi tout le public qui se
balade dans le parc promenade qui sont
là pour faire des barbecue en famille
qui sont pour se balader pour faire un
tour de de Rosalie ou un tour de manège
à côté et qui viennent du coup dans le
village et qui là bah vont s'initier
découvrir des activités sportives
organisé depuis 6 ans sur le site
l'événement propose également depuis
2015 des sports axés sur le handicap les
participants ont pu notamment réaliser
des parcours en fauteuil ou jouer au
showon un sport créé dans les années 60
au Canada le showon est un tennis de top
pour déficient visuel il y a une
raquette une balle et bien sûr on a
masque pour que tout le monde soit au
même niveau visuel et le but du jeu
c'est d'envoyer la balle dans le but on
perd les repères parce que nous en tant
que voyant on a on veut regarder ce qui
se passe alors que justement dans le
Showdown il faut écouter ce qu'il se
passe difficile pourquoi parce que on
narrêtait pas de marquer des buts ça
fait appel au sens de l'audition ça nous
pr du sens de la vue c'est ça fait
bizarre quoi après avoir attiré plus de
500 personnes cette année l'événement
sentez-vous sport tentera de viser plus
haut l'année prochaine et de battre son
record de 3000
participants